avec nous docteur Marie-Eve coton que
vous connaissez médecin psychiatre
professeur bonsoir docteur coton bonsoir
Patrice je parlais à un de vos collègues
tout à l'heure docteur Chamberland et
qui faisait une différence importante
parce que pour nous qui regardons ça ce
matin on dit il est fou là ça prend un
fou pour s'attaquer à des jeunes enfants
victimes là dans une garderie impuissant
des petits bouts de chou mais entre le
langage populaire de quelqu'un est fou
et la folie
codifiée il y a un pas il y a une marge
là où vous en êtes dans votre réflexion
on est quelques heures après le drame ce
matin
c'est des questions importantes c'est à
dire qu'il y a pas de doute je pense
pour n'importe qui que c'était cet
individu-là devait être souffrant devait
être en détresse maintenant être en
détresse puis être malade c'est deux
choses différentes et c'est important de
le mentionner moi mon message est
beaucoup de dire attention
diagnostic précipité de problèmes de
maladies mentales dans les heures
suivant une tuerie comme celle-là je
trouve que c'est beaucoup ce qui s'est
passé suite à la tuerie du Vieux Québec
où les ministres les journalistes
parlaient de troubles de santé mentale
avant même que psychiatre est rencontré
l'individu donc c'est important parce
que les camps on regarde les études sur
les soirs de masse il y en a 22% qui ont
une maladie mentale importante le haut
que le problème de consommation un
trouble de personnalité donc c'est
possible que cet individu là a été sous
l'emprise une psychose ou
d'hallucinations mais ce n'est pas
l'unique possibilité ce n'est même pas
la possibilité la plus importante sur le
plan statistique donc c'est important de
de garder l'esprit ouvert de pas
spéculer de façon stérile avec seulement
des brides d'information parce que ce
qui arrive c'est que dans des traces
j'ai dit comme ça très morbide on est
très pro à parler de de maladies
mentales et ça stigmatise énormément les
gens qui ont des maladies mentales vous
savez aujourd'hui les gens dans la
population ils ont deux points 5 plus de
chances qu'en 1950 de dire que les gens
qui sautent de schizophrénie sont
violents et je pense que cette
association là médiatique entre une
espèce d'automatisme de ce genre associé
cette ce genre de tuerie avec la maladie
mentale elle est très très néfaste pour
les gens qui ont des problèmes de santé
mentale je comprends très bien et au
terme de la loi c'est loin d'être sûr
même si lui plaidait la non
responsabilité pour cause d'aliénation
mentale c'est loin d'être sûr qu'il
obtiendrait c'est difficile à faire la
preuve mais je reviens à la réaction
normale que nous avons devant ces drames
là est-ce qu'une personne saine d'esprit
peut commettre ce genre d'action là
une personne
une personne qui est parfaitement
équilibrée qui est une vie épanouissante
et tout ça non mais on n'a pas besoin
d'être malade pour être malheureux ça
c'est vraiment le message que j'ai à
transmettre c'est à dire que le profil
des gens qui font des sur une masse
c'est des très majoritairement des
hommes très majoritairement des
individus qui sont isolés socialement
ils sont pas bien intégrés dans la
société dans un emploi dans une famille
etc sont plutôt les gens solitaires ils
ont souvent des problèmes de
consommation ils ont souvent subi du de
l'exclusion et du bowling c'est-à-dire
de du harcèlement soulever ou de
l'intimidation dans leur vie donc ils
peuvent avoir une certaine rencard donc
ils ont souvent un vécu et motif
lourd difficile mais c'est pas parce
qu'on souffre parce qu'on est intimidé
qu'on a une maladie mentale
et les gens qui versent en des crimes
haineux souvent la haine et la violence
va s'alimenter de la détresse c'est à
dire que quand les gens sont pas heureux
sont pas satisfaits de leur vie qui ont
et qui ont subi eux-mêmes de la violence
ou qui ont été témoins ils vont plus
facilement verser dans des crimes mais
la haine comme telle c'est pas une
maladie mentale il faut faire la
distinction c'est intéressant l'air
n'est pas une maladie mentale ce qui ce
qui entraîne un niveau de haine comme
celui-là qui peut expliquer un geste
comme ça c'est c'est des c'est difficile
à concevoir vous allez reconnaître avec
moi si tu fais la concevoir pour un
parent entre guillemets normal mais vous
dites c'est pas dire qu'il était fou là
non le mot folie je ne le contrôle pas
parce que c'est pas un terme médical
donc si les gens veulent dire c'est
quelque chose que je trouve fou c'est
pas la si nécessairement mon combat mais
c'est pas tous les gestes immoraux ne
sont pas de la maladie mentale la
maladie mentale c'est pas une espèce de
bassin non spécifique où on peut mettre
tous les les comportements humains qui
sont
morbides ou qui je veux dire
tragique ou qui sont immoraux ou qui
sont violents c'est plus compliqué que
ça et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs je vous
laissais aller je pense vous devez y
aller c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
devant les tribunaux je le répète c'est
important ce n'est pas parce qu'on
plaide la liation mentale puis que la
déconnexion avec le réel qu'on l'obtient
là c'est tombé dans une case maladie
mentale c'est pas facile en cours en
fait c'est que les gens sont saines
d'esprit jusqu'à preuve du contrat sont
présumés sain d'esprit pour être trouver
non responsables il faut prouver deux
choses soit que la personne savait pas
ce qu'elle faisait donc elle savait pas
que rentrer dans avec le bus pouvait
tuer quelqu'un ou que pensait pas que
c'était mal par exemple si la personne
est sous le coup d'hallucination qui lui
dit faut que tu poses ce geste là pour
sauver l'humanité parce qu'elle est sous
l'emprise d'un délire en disant ça va
être la fin du monde tu le fais pas là
les gens le font mais on l'impression de
faire ça pour le bien si vous voulez là
si l'avocat peut montrer ça là ça va
conduire mais même si on a une maladie
mentale ça c'est important aussi on peut
avoir une maladie mentale mais qui était
pas suffisamment sévère pour que
justement soit on sache pas ce qu'on
faisait ou on sache pas que c'était mal
donc même la maladie mentale c'est pas
un passeport automatique vers l'avion
responsabilité criminelle très bien
docteur coton on va se reparler là parce
que en fait le message que vous envoyez
c'est à l'ont pas trouvé puis on
comprend le message pour mettre des
étiquettes de maladies mentales parce
que des gens qui sont vraiment malades
mentaux
qui sont en proie des maladies mentales
qui ne veulent pas être associés
injustement à ces folies là absolument
et les gens qui souffrent de maladies
mentales sont très peu violents en fait
ils sont beaucoup plus à risque d'être
victime de violence que d'être eux-mêmes
désagresseur donc faut pas rajouter à
leur adversité docteur merci à la
prochaine au revoir